regarding the condition of the person
who's performing EA is he or she allowed
to leave the confines of the mosque
normally while doing EA a person should
not leave the mosque if he leaves the
mosque he breaks the principle of EA and
the EA is
invalidated but in case of emergency if
there is a need then he can leave for
example if a person wants to go for Call
of nature if wants to go to leave
himself or if he wants to do woodo or do
Gul or to have a bath or wash himself or
if there is no one who can get food for
him in the mosque and if he has to go to
eat he's allowed to go out to get
food so unless it's a basic necessity
it's a need as it's mentioned inkari
volume number three in the book of
Hadith number
2029 pleas with her she says the prophet
while doinga never entered the house
unless it was for a
need so if it's necessity is allowed
otherwise and normal circumstances you
should not leave the mosque and if you
have to leave for a basic necessity you
have to come back fast as soon as
possible but nowaday alhamdulillah many
MOS or most of the mosque they have a
toilet attached to the mosque they have
a bathroom attached to it and the woodoo
is inside the m so there are less
requirements to go out of the mosque and
furthermore the wife of the
Prophet she said it's mentioned in Abu
da volume number two in the book of
fasting Hadith number
2467 that a person who does it is theah
of that he should not visit a patient or
attend a funeral or embrace the wife or
have relationship with the wife
and should not leave the Mosk unless for
a basic necessity here we come to know
that while
doing it is not a
Sunnah it's not allowed that you should
visit a person who's sick or visit a
relative or go out for family needs or
for earning money or for a funeral
except for a basic need you should not
leave the mosque okay that seems to be
quite clear in terms of the the basic
requirements of IA